[Music]
heather locklear arrested amidst
concerns that she is spiraling out of
control the 56 year old actress is
accused of striking her boyfriend and
then bully police officers you know this
isn't the first time Locklear has been
in trouble with the law she has
struggled with alcohol and substance
abuse and now police are investigating
what made Heather allegedly go on the
attack inside her own home Heather
Locklear was booked on a domestic
violence charge just after 1:00 this
morning a source tells e.t Heather was
out of control last night and got in a
fight with her boyfriend her brother
called police the situation allegedly
escalated when deputies arrived in her
LA area home quote she was screaming at
the police and went on the attack
Locklear also faces three counts of
misdemeanor battery on a police officer
about the same time Heather was being
booked her boyfriend Chris Heisler was
arrested on a DUI charge the 56 year old
actress who has reportedly been to rehab
five times has a history of problems
with drugs and alcohol in 2008 she was
arrested for suspicion of driving under
the influence she pleaded no contest to
reckless driving and the DUI charge was
dropped in 2012 she was rushed to the
hospital after reportedly mixing alcohol
and prescription medication medically
we're glad to report that Heather is
some stable as far as domestic violence
issues in 2011 LAPD officers were
dispatched to the home of Heather's ex
actor Jack Wagner a source at the time
tells ET the actress punched him that
same source also told us
Heather hit rock star Richie Sambora
while they were married it's important
to point out however that last night's
incident is the first time Heather has
been arrested on charges of domestic
violence et has been on set with Heather
since the 80s I'm just taking it as it
comes and hopefully staying level-headed
about it she was Sammy Jo on dynasty
I've had all the catfights I can handle
and bad girl Amanda on Melrose plays
that's enough
Heather recently appeared on fresh off
the boat and as the first lady on TLC is
too close to home I'm not a dream I'm
real writing it's like one of the best
things that I've ever gotten to do our
source tells us Locklear's family is
urging her to get help adding quote last
night was rock bottom for Heather
Locklear is set to appear in court on
March 13th
[Music]